tres personas incluido un niño fueron
encontradas vivas 12 días después de los
terremotos que ya dejan más de 45.000
muertos en Turquía y Siria hoy también
Se confirmó el hallazgo del cuerpo sin
vida de un futbolista de la selección
ganesa
fortalecer la otan y evitar una escalada
nuclear con Irán estas son parte de lo
que se ha propuesto los líderes
occidentales reunidos por segundo día en
la conferencia de seguridad de Múnich
además de Ucrania china también se roba
la atención en el encuentro
en Francia fracasó un intento de la
oposición para censurar al gobierno por
su controvertido proyecto de reforma
pensional el álgido debate en la
asamblea nacional ya cobró su primera
víctima política con la destitución del
segundo al mando del partido con su
conservador los republicanos
Bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en France 24 yo soy Daniela
Blandón comenzamos en Turquía donde
resurgió la esperanza 12 días después
del terremoto que sacudió al país un
niño y sus padres fueron encontrados con
vida tras permanecer 296 horas bajo los
escombros según medios locales los
equipos de rescate lograron sacarlos de
las ruinas de un edificio de
apartamentos en la ciudad sureña de
antioquía Aunque el niño murió horas
después por deshidratación entre tanto
en la región de hatay fue hallado el
cuerpo sin vida del futbolista de la
selección ganesa Cristian atzu Los
Fuertes movimientos telúricos del seis
de febrero y sus posteriores réplicas
han dejado hasta el momento cerca de
40.000 muertos en Turquía también se
cuentan unas 5000 víctimas en Siria que
ahora recibe de vuelta a los refugiados
que buscaban un futuro digno en el país
vecino y ahora deben regresar a lo que
queda de sus hogares más en el siguiente
informe de Marina sardinha
una capa más de precariedad para una
población extremadamente frágil los
sismos que devastaron parte del sur de
Turquía y el noroeste de Siria dejaron
sin viviendas a miles de refugiados
sirios huyeron de Siria por la guerra
ahora sin alternativas regresan a su
país Pese a que el conflicto todavía
continúa la historia hay problemas en
Siria tú mismo lo sabes pero ahora mismo
el mayor problema está en Turquía en
Siria hay problemas desde hace 12 años
Siria está en ruinas pero ahora mismo la
mayor catástrofe está en Turquía
más de cuatro millones de sirios Residen
en Turquía desde que inició la Guerra en
2011 las regiones asoladas por la
catástrofe acogían a casi dos millones
de refugiados ankara cambió la normativa
de movilidad de la población refugiada
permitiendo a los sirios que cuentan con
documentos de identidad salir de Turquía
por un período de 3 a 6 meses para
reunirse así con sus familias del otro
lado de la frontera
perdí mi casa y desde el terremoto he
estado viviendo en un parque nos dieron
tiendas de campaña pero todo es para
mostrar Así que decidí regresar y vivir
en mi país vivo muerto prefiero estar
con mi familia
otros no podrán regresar bien porque lo
han perdido todo en su nación o por
amenazas de los grupos armados o el
régimen autoritario de bashar al asad el
segmento de sirios refugiados en Turquía
están en el escalafón más bajo de de la
sociedad obviamente más frágiles con
mayor precariedad y con una situación
mucho más complicada no pueden volver a
su casa seguramente su casa está
destruida y ya sea por la guerra ya sea
por el terremoto y en Turquía en una
situación de absoluta destrucción
también en todo el sur del país pues
obviamente esto añade Mayor Mayor
precariedad y mayor fragilidad económica
más de mil refugiados sirios han
fallecido en los sismos del lado Turco
muchos cuerpos están siendo repatriados
para ser enterrados en sus lugares de
origen
cambiamos de información con una
invitación a fortalecer la otan y a
evitar un conflicto nuclear con Irán
inició la segunda de tres jornadas de la
conferencia de Munich un espacio en el
que Ucrania está en el foco del debate a
menos de una semana de cumplirse un año
del inicio de la invasión rusa después
del llamado de la comisión europea
Francia y Alemania para acelerar la
producción de municiones para kiev el
jefe de la
otanberg dijo que espera para el corto
plazo la adhesión de Finlandia y Suecia
e instó a seguir ampliando la alianza
Las Guerras son impredecibles y no
sabemos cuándo ni cómo terminará esta
pero si sé esto Incluso si la guerra
termina mañana nuestro entorno de
seguridad ha cambiado a largo plazo no
hay vuelta atrás el kremlin quiere una
Europa diferente Una en la que Rusia
controla a sus vecinos
también sabemos que Beijing está
observando de cerca el precio que paga
Rusia o la recompensa que recibe por su
agresión lo que está sucediendo en
Europa hoy podría suceder en Asia mañana
y en esa misma conferencia china
aprovechó para criticar a Estados Unidos
por el manejo que le ha dado al hallazgo
de un globo procedente de este país que
rodeaba la costa atlántica antes de ser
derribado a comienzos de este mes
Washington sospecha que se trata de un
globo espía y Beijing lo niega
desafortunadamente Estados Unidos no
prestó atención a estos hechos y en su
lugar utilizó aviones de combate aviones
de combate modernos para derribar un
globo de misiles diría que esta es una
reacción Absurda e histérica y
absolutamente un abuso de fuerza
y continuamos hablando del continente
asiático esta vez para hablar de un
nuevo misil balístico lanzado este
sábado por Corea del Norte que cayó
sobre territorio marítimo japonés según
las autoridades el ejército surcoreano
sospecha que se trata de un misil de
largo alcance es el segundo lanzamiento
que realiza Peón yang en lo que va del
año después de que en 2022 se registrara
un número récord en torno a medio
centenar Corea del Sur convocó a una
reunión de emergencia del Consejo de
Seguridad nacional para abordar este
nuevo ensayo
y nos vamos a Francia en donde el
proyecto de ley de reforma pensional del
gobierno de Manuel macron cobró su
primera víctima política el partido
conservador los republicanos destituyó a
su vicepresidente ojelia por los cambios
que propuso sobre la iniciativa Pese a
que el gobierno necesita el apoyo de la
colectividad para sacar adelante la
iniciativa El proyecto fue debatido sin
éxito en la asamblea nacional y ahora
pasa al senado
Finalizó el debate sobre la reforma a
las pensiones en la asamblea nacional
francesa vamos a interrumpir la revisión
del proyecto de ley suspendo la sesión
la primera revisión del proyecto de ley
terminó sin votación en medio de un
ambiente tenso los diputados sólo
alcanzaron a discutir hasta el artículo
siete de la Reforma que prevé el retraso
de la edad legal de jubilación de 62 a
64 años la mayoría de los diputados
reconoció el fracaso y acusó de
obstrucción a la izquierda que presentó
miles de enmiendas
no hemos podido debatir estas enmiendas
y para nosotros ese decepcionante
teníamos ideas puntos de vista que ahora
todo el país para que el país entendiera
nuestra posición y se ha creado tal
desorden esto es terrible pero es una
realidad de los debates
lupes acusa al gobierno de no haber
dejado espacio para el debate al optar
por acelerar la revisión del texto en la
asamblea
lamentamos profundamente que un debate
de tal magnitud e importancia para los
franceses y francesas no pueda continuar
y llegar hasta el final es decir con un
examen serio que requiere tiempo el
final de la sesión También estuvo
marcado por la moción de censura contra
el gobierno presentaban la asamblea
nacional como era de esperar fue
ampliamente rechazada el texto deberá
estudiarse ahora en el senado durante 15
días
fuera del parlamento las protestas
continúan los sindicatos anunciaron una
nueva huelga a partir del 7 de marzo
según varios sondeos dos tercios de los
franceses se oponen a la reforma del
gobierno maco
y la cifra de víctimas por el paso del
ciclón Gabriel siguen aumentando en
Nueva Zelanda este sábado las
autoridades informaron que ya son nueve
los muertos mientras que todavía hay
miles de civiles sin localizar las
tormentas dejaron sin luz a más de
60.000 hogares que quedaron llenos de
lodo y arruinaron cosechas de
exportación Ramiro cuevar berena con el
informe
el ciclón Gabriel dejó un sendero de
devastación en la vida de los habitantes
de Nueva Zelanda es el caso de tajuranji
residente de Caracas quien vio como su
casa se llena de lodo
ha pasado por aquí a través de los
dormitorios la cocina y todos los
armarios los voluntarios ayudaron a esta
mujer mayor tan solo uno de los
damnificados que dejó el ciclón
una lavadora nunca se ha usado
es nueva para estrenar
además de daños civiles la tormentas
también azotaron los campos de cultivos
para exportaciones
es un cultivo de kiwi y como se mojó por
la inundación ya no se puede exportar
por lo que tendremos que despojarlo si
el cultivo sobrevive no lo sabemos en
este momento pero tiene 300 milímetros
de limo y el kiwi posiblemente morirá
como resultado de eso
las autoridades continúan actualizando
la cifra de fallecidos y hay temor por
aquellos sitios que permanecen
incomunicados
hemos publicado información sobre todas
las muertes de las que tenemos
conocimiento hasta ahora no tenemos
ningún otro cuerpo que esté con nosotros
A pesar de los rumores de que esto
abundó en la comunidad Durante los
últimos días y continuaremos con nuestra
investigación forense proceso que es
bastante estricto en la identificación
de cuerpos a medida que los obtenemos
actualmente hay casi 5.000 personas que
la policía no ha podido localizar y
alrededor de 62.000 hogares sin
electricidad mientras el gobierno
continúa sus esfuerzos por llevar
toneladas de comida y agua potable a las
comunidades afectadas
cambiamos de territorio comenzó este
sábado la Cumbre de la unión africana
que reúne a líderes de las 55 naciones
de este continente y que se centra en la
profundización de la crisis alimentaria
y de seguridad en la región el
secretario general de Naciones Unidas
Antonio Gutiérrez advirtió que los
países africanos muy endeudados están
recibiendo un trato Injusto del sistema
financiero internacional con tasas de
interés exorbitantes nuestra enviada
especial adisabebán Marian coné nos
reportó previamente sobre la cita la
tristísima reunión de los jefes de
estado de la unión africana comenzó esta
mañana con 20 minutos de retraso hace
apenas unos minutos casi todos los
presidentes del continente han pasado
por este pasillo para llegar a la sala
de conferencia Nelson Mandela así pues
aunque hoy sea el día más importante de
la Cumbre porque se han se harán muchos
anuncios no no debemos olvidar que jefe
de estado están en aresa me va desde
ayer y han realizado muchas reuniones
bilaterales en estas primeras reuniones
dominó el tema de la inseguridad por
ejemplo hubo una región sobre la
situación del conflicto en el este de la
República democrática del Congo que
resultó en una decisión importante la
exigencia por parte de la unión africana
de La retirada de los grupos armados de
la región del cubo antes del día 30 de
marzo estamos solo al principio de esta
primera jornada que estará con muchos
anuncios en particular sobre la cuestión
de la puesta en marcha del proyecto de
zona africana de libre comercio
y terminamos con noticias del que bien
puede ser el fenómeno deportivo del año
en España hablamos de la Kings League
este híbrido entre los videojuegos y el
fútbol ha sido creado por el exjugador
del Barcelona geraton Piqué en conjunto
con el célebre influencer ibai Llanos el
torneo bate récords de audiencia en las
plataformas digitales un equipo de
France 24 estuvo en las entrañas de este
certamen
un estadio indoor cámaras en cada
esquina y streamers como presidentes de
los equipos Bienvenidos a la kingsley
una nueva era del deporte
Juan es entrenador esta mezcla de
videojuego y fútbol le permite utilizar
una tarjeta especial en cualquier
momento pero solo una vez por partido
cuando quieran activar la carta de
presidente vale antes de activarla y
luego ya pulsas el pulsador vale
esta arma secreta le permite al
entrenador activar un penal o hacer que
un gol valga el doble o el triple
este fútbol 7 fue concebido
especialmente para internet y consta de
dos medios tiempos de 20 minutos ya que
estamos muy tranquilos porque no hay
público no hay tanta presión pero pero
bueno al final cada decisión es muy
determinante porque hay mucha gente
viéndonos por detrás Adri es el
presidente de uno de los dos equipos del
torneo a sus 26 años este influenciador
suma tres millones y medio de seguidores
en tiktok
reaccionando al anterior partido del
barrio que ya la subida a mi canal de
YouTube siempre subo las reacciones
analizando mi partido Al haber tantos
elementos tantas cartas tanto tanta cosa
no le da tiempo a pestañear Por así
decirlo entonces tendría que estar muy
atento porque todo el rato están pasando
cosas y la duración Yo creo que es clave
las audiencias de la Kings League
molestan a algunos como a Javier tebas
el presidente de la liga española que
comparó este juego a un circo para este
periodista bien Podría agitar la marea
uno de los mayores impactos en
entretenimiento de los últimos cinco
años o
relacionado con el deporte eso no me
cabe duda el fútbol en general debería
plantearse si no hay que renovar algunas
cosas la final de la Kings League se
disputará el 26 de Marzo en el mítico
hasta que ese informativo quédense con
nosotros en France 24